Das kommt mir bekannt vor.
Genau, das ist das.
Das wollte ich mal spielen.
Das habe ich in irgendeinem...
Ich glaube in einem Speedrun-Marathon mal gesehen.
Das sieht so ein bisschen Metroid-Style mäßig aus.
Wenn ich das hier, also zumindest auf den ersten Eindruck,
wo man das hier mit dieser Übersichtskarte, wo man das gerade gesehen hat,
in unterschiedlichen Räumen und sowas.
Kennt das jemand?
Hat das jemand schon gespielt?
Mr. Viech, mag spielst du eigentlich noch Konsole?
Ja, öfters. Also Switch hauptsächlich.
Ich meine, man sieht es jetzt hier nicht.
Ich habe jetzt hier den riesen Konsolenturm mittlerweile links neben mir stehen.
Das steht unten.
Unten steht... Moment, was ist denn das, was unten steht?
Das ist die Xbox One, die unten steht.
Das Fetteste von allen ist die Xbox One.
Das ist die Release von 2013.
Xbox One.
Dann drüber stehen habe ich die 360.
Danach habe ich eine Wii U und eine PS4.
Und die Switch steht drüben.
Wo ist eigentlich meine PS3?
Ah, die steht unten im Regal.
Okay.
Hollow Knight ist richtig gut.
Ich glaube, man kann da auch nicht allzu viel falsch machen,
wenn man jetzt nicht...
Das waren 9,89 Euro.
Xbox, da wo sie hingehört, ganz unten.
Die Xbox, die habe ich...
Also ich habe ja diesen...
Wo ist denn der Controller?
Da steht irgendwie sowas...
Egal, ich brauche jetzt die Controller nicht.
Aber auf dem Xbox-Controller steht irgendwie sowas drauf wie
2013 Xbox Release Edition.
Und ich habe die Konsole vielleicht insgesamt 5 Stunden angehabt, seit 2013.
Und ich muss euch noch was zeigen, falls es davon was gibt.
Ich habe da nämlich, glaube ich, kein Foto von.
Ich habe nämlich ein T-Shirt von Microsoft.
Das ist absolut die brutalste Übertreibung aller Zeiten.
Ich hoffe, es hat jemand von diesem T-Shirt ein Foto gemacht.
Dann kann ich es euch nämlich mal zeigen.
Nee, fuck.
Nee, ich finde es nicht.
Ich habe nämlich von Microsoft ein T-Shirt.
Übelst dick aufgetragen.
Da waren wir damals auf der Gamescom.
Also quasi noch bevor die Gamescom losgegangen ist.
Am ersten Tag bei Microsoft.
Und wir waren da irgendwie...
Das haben wir erst später gemerkt.
Ich glaube, die Story habe ich schon mal erzählt.
Microsoft hat halt so gefragt.
Ja und, Jungs?
Wollt ihr vorbeikommen?
Ja, klar.
Cool.
Können wir uns das angucken?
Gibt es danach was zu futtern?
Geil.
Gucken wir uns an.
Also wir wurden quasi direkt von Microsoft eingeladen.
Felix und ich.
Und haben gesagt, ja, machen wir.
Bis wir es dann gecheckt haben, als wir drinnen waren.
Wir haben gesagt, ja, machen wir.
Als sie uns...
Als sie wollten, dass wir uns Xbox-T-Shirts anziehen und in die ersten zwei Reihen hocken.
Wir waren quasi die Vorklatscher für die Microsoft-Presse...
Also die Anfeuerer für die Microsoft-Pressekonferenz.
Ich glaube, das habe ich euch schon mal erzählt.
Zumindest seit dem Tag habe ich so ein komisches Xbox-T-Shirt.
Das ist eines meiner Lieblings-T-Shirts, weil es passt echt gut.
Wahrscheinlich haben sie sich gedacht, die Leute, die da kommen, sind eh alle mega fett.
Deswegen brauchen wir fette T-Shirts.
Und seitdem habe ich ein Xbox-T-Shirt, wo hinten ganz bescheiden, so wie Microsoft ist, draufsteht.
Ich war...
Also sinngemäß steht da drauf.
Ich war dabei, als die größten Games aller Zeiten gezeigt wurden.
Das müsst ihr euch vorstellen.
Das war die Gamescom 2014 oder so.
Microsoft-Pressekonferenz.
Wo sie unter anderem Scalebound oder Spellbound?
Bound?
Stings?
Wie hieß das?
Scalebound?
Ich glaube, Scalebound hieß das.
Gezeigt haben...
Ja, ich habe sogar noch ein Scalebound.
Spellbound?
Wie heißt denn das Game mit dem Drache, was sie jetzt eingestellt haben?
Nee.
Scalebound hieß das, ne?
Scalebound.
Genau.
Ich habe sogar noch ein Scalebound-T-Shirt und das ist ja mittlerweile eingestellt.
Das haben sie mit Riesentamtam da angekündigt und jetzt halt eingestellt.
So.
Seitdem habe ich so ein Xbox-T-Shirt, wo halt ganz bescheiden und fett draufsteht.
I witnessed the greatest games of all time.
Xbox.
So.
Also, das Game, das habe ich mal in einem Stream gesehen.
Das ist echt ganz nice.
Ich glaube, das machen wir uns auch mal in Card.
Hoffentlich zeigt es nicht meine Adresse an Steam, ey.
Okay, was haben wir...
Was gibt es denn sonst noch?
Das haben wir uns schon angeguckt.
Was ist das?
Er hat auch alles, oder?
Der hat auch alles.
Der ist ja überall an jedem Game, wo ich hier drüber gehe.
One friend owns this game.
Der hat auch alles.
Gibt nichts, was er nicht hat.
Was ist das?
Weltraumstelz.
Oh, das ist was von Fabian.
Übrigens, mit dem Friseur kommt nachher ein Video.
Wir haben gestern was zusammen aufgenommen.
Oh, ich muss mal Chat lesen.
Fällt mir gerade ein.
Das sieht mir ein bisschen aus nach Weltraumstelz.
Grafisch ganz hübscher Weltraumstelz, muss ich sagen.
Grafisch ganz hübscher Weltraumstelz.
Der echte.
Ja, der echte, ja.
Haha.
Wollte ich eigentlich um 13 Uhr freischalten.
Mal gucken, wann wir mit dem Stream fertig sind.
Max hat irgendwo mal gesagt, dass er ein offizielles FaceReveal macht, wenn er eine Million Subs bekommt.
Das habe ich echt mal gesagt.
So, was haben wir ansonsten noch?
Ja.
Planet Coaster.
Na.
Auch wenn ich früher die, wie hieß es denn, Railroad Tycoon, Railroad, Railcoaster Tycoon
oder das, ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Übelst geil fand.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es an die alten Teile rankommt.
Was sagen denn die Bewertungen?
Rollercoaster Tycoon.
Genau.
Ja, stimmt.
PTF.
Hahaha.
Ist einfach mal alles zusammengewischt an Wordson.
Die Leute finden es anscheinend übelst geil und die finden es nicht geil.
Watching Videos.
Na gut, das ist ja nicht schlimm, wenn es ein Simulator ist mit einer gewissen Tiefe,
ist das ja okay.
Und das ist irgendwas, das gucke ich mir irgendwann später mal an.
Das ist jetzt nichts, was ich unmittelbar spielen muss.
Ja.
Hey Max, findest du Spellforce 3 interessant?
Sofern die Bugs mittlerweile behoben sind, dass man das spielen kann.
Arc.
Nope.
Wir sind da eigentlich so die letzten Bewertungen.
Das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken.
Mixed.
Ja, das, das wundert mich nicht.
Ah.
Das ist auch so ein Game.
Early Access, mega erfolgreich gestartet und dann ziemlich abgebaut.
Aber, wollen wir auch sagen.
Ich habe selten so gehypte Entwickler gesehen, wie die von Arc.
Und wie gesagt, keine Marketingmenschen, sondern wirklich die Entwickler, die an dem
Spiel gebastelt haben.
Was ist das?
Das ist irgendwie so ein Physik-Game.
Ich hoffe nicht in der Qualität eines Go-Simulators.
Physics-based puzzle and exploration game.
Das Problem, was ich mit solchen Games immer habe, ist.
Die machen mir meistens nach 5 Minuten keinen Bock mehr.
Ne, ich glaube, das ist nicht meins.
Streamer-Game.
Ja, genau.
Genau.
Sowas in der Richtung.
Hätte ich auch gedacht.
Okay, der Chat sagt, das Game ist gut.
Vielleicht gucke ich mir das irgendwann mal an.
Total War.
Nope.
Nicht meine Serie.
Nochmal Dark Souls.
Juckt mich aber jetzt nicht.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Großartig.
Also habe ich jetzt auch nicht vor.
Skyrim.
Das habe ich noch nicht.
Den ersten Teil habe ich auf der Konsole.
Also den ersten Teil ist...
Es ist mittlerweile so schlimm, ja, wenn du spiele Serien mit erster und zweiter Teil und sowas.
Das ergibt dann oftmals überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Guckt euch jetzt nur mal Battlefront an.
Das gibt es jetzt einfach...
Gibt es Battlefront 2?
Gibt es jetzt zweimal.
Und ich bin mal...
Ich bin echt mal gespannt.
Wenn das nächste Battlefield was rauskommt, im Zweiten Weltkrieg spielt.
Ich hoffe, sie sind nicht versucht, es Battlefield 2 zu nennen.
Weil dann wäre echt die Kacke...
Das wäre einfach mindblown, wisst ihr?
Wenn das Battlefield im Jahr 2018 Battlefield 2 heißen würde.
Und irgendwie wäre es auch ziemlich dumm, wenn sie es so wie Call of Duty machen, dass es Battlefield World War 2 heißt.
Wäre auch doof.
Sie könnten es mal ganz anders nennen.
Oder sie könnten es auch alternativ einfach Battlefield 5 nennen.
Oder wie der Schnetzelortz im Chat schreibt, Battlefield 2.1.
Battlefield 2.
Milchmann, du sagst was.
Das ist EA-Logik.
Wahrscheinlich heißt das allen Ernstes Battlefield 2.
Weil sie waren ja auch bei Battlefield 1 immer ganz wild drauf, dass man es halt immer...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das jetzt mit Zahlen schreiben sollte oder mit 1.
Es gab eine von EA bevorzugte Schreibweise, die sie einem immer nahelegen wollten.
So nach dem Motto, war Battlefield 1.
Wahrscheinlich nennen sie das dann nicht Battlefield 2 als Zahl, sondern Battlefield 2.
Ausgeschrieben.
Das könnte ich mir gut vorstellen.
Das wäre so eine typische EA-Taktik.
Was geht ab, Gamers?
No Second Plan ist auch da.
Das wollte ich mir mal angucken.
Das neue Civilization.
Weiß nicht, ob das was taugt, der Teil.
Und das ist wieder was, wo du 30.000 DLCs brauchst, dass du spielen darfst.
Reason Reef is mixed.
But why?
Warum?
Die Leute finden es kacke.
Don't buy this.
Do not play this.
Okay.
Ja gut, Steam-Bewertung.
Die AI soll nicht so gut sein.
Aha.
Das neue Civilization bietet weit weniger als das alte mit ganzen DLCs.
Achso.
Das wird natürlich auch die negativen Bewertungen erklären.
Das verstehe ich eh nicht so genau.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie bei Sims.
Bei Sims hast du einen Teil, da gibt es dann gefühlt 150 DLCs von Haustieren bis Teppichfarben zu, ähm, wir gehen in einen Tierarzt-DLC oder sonstige Dinger, ja.
Da gibt es dann alles, gefühlt.
Und da kommt der neue Sims-Teil raus und da fehlt dann halt alles, was früher alles zu uns dazugekommen ist.
Eigentlich wäre Sims so ein typisches Game, was du so, um es mal buzzwordmäßig zu sagen, so Game-as-a-Service anbieten kannst.
Ja.
Schnitt zu hast.
Hey Max, feierst du heute mit deiner Familie?
Mit meiner Mutter.
Ja.
Haustier-DLC, beste DLC.
Da haben sie, das, ich, was war, ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir da live vor Ort waren.
Es könnte sein.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob wir, ob wir, doch, ich glaube, da haben wir vor Ort da gehockt, wo sie den, für Sims, den Haustier, den Haustier-DLC vorgestellt haben.
Und halt so super amazed und toll waren.
Und dann hatten sie noch einen Typ, der hat Tricks mit einem, ich weiß nicht, was es für eine Hunderasse war, irgendwelche Hundetricks oder so vorgeführt und hat dann halt versucht, das Publikum für sich zu gewinnen.
Und alle Leute haben nur da gesessen und haben sich gedacht, so ey, das ist Sims, das ist ein Haustier-DLC, so who cares, ja.
Außer halt die üblichen Klatscher, die halt bezahlt werden zum Klatschen, die waren natürlich auch in Abstand.
Ja, was haben wir denn hier sonst noch am Start?
Fallout 4 DLC, nope.
Rust, nein.
Ohne eine Aussage über das Game treffen zu wollen, da steige ich bestimmt nicht mit ein.
Das haben wir uns gerade schon angeguckt, das Stick Fighting Game.
Fallout 4, nope, auch keinen Bock drauf.
The Long Dark, das sagt mir was.
Das sagt mir irgendwas, kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
Was war denn das nochmal? Ist das das in diesem Naturschutz?
Ne, das war Firewatch oder wie das hieß.
In diesem Park.
The Long Dark.
Och nee.
Open World Survival, immer Open World Survival.
Wo du hinguckst, Open World Survival, fällt dir in allen nichts mehr besseres ein.
Ist gar nicht auf das Spiel bezogen, das mag ja gut sein, vor allem wenn man sich die Bewertungen und so anguckt.
Aber muss es denn immer nur noch Open World Survival sein?
Sieht echt hübsch aus, muss ich sagen.
Gut, die Bäume sehen hässlich aus, ja, aber das von der Belichtung her und so und die Szene an sich sieht echt gut aus.
Das Game ist echt nicht schlecht, okay?
Wir machen gleich auch ein bisschen fetzigere Weihnachtsmusik an.
Jetzt habe ich gerade fetzig gesagt, das erinnert mich an den Fnatic Headshot Pro Controller oder wie dieses Ding hieß.
Kennt ihr das noch?
Moment, das muss ich...
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Wartet mal, Leute.
Moment, Moment.
Ich muss mal den Browser aufmachen.
Das müssen wir uns jetzt zusammen angucken.
Moment, Moment.
gerade dabei sind ich würde mal kurz die musik einblenden display capture was war
auf beste beste hier der der fanatec headshot controller beste wenn
computerspielen die nase vorn haben will braucht eine top ausstattung genau das
richtige das set besteht aus präzisen gamer maus und einem high speed pad zusammen ein
unschlagbares team die maus ist super ergonomisch und lässt sich an jede handform anpassen das sorgt
auch in langen gamer sessions für ermüdungsfreies spielen sechs maus buttons und ein fünf wege
steuerrad sorgen dafür dass sie ihre spielfigur auch in heißen gefechten haben die plasma gleit
maus füße sorgen zusammen mit dem high speed pad für minimale haft und gleit reibung für schnelles
präzise
zielen im spiel kommt ihnen dabei garantiert nicht in die quere dafür sorgt die clevere
kabelführung fetzige leuchteffekte mit unterschiedlichen farben helligkeit und
pulsfrequenz machen das spiel noch rasanter das hier das ist das beschissenste maus bungee was
ich jemals gesehen habe das sieht aus wie eine sicherungskette für einkaufswagen die
40 pass auf jetzt die fetzigen leuchte effekte die muss man zwar mal angucken helligkeit und
pulsfrequenz machen das spiel noch rasanter profi-gamer sind begeistert von den programmier
möglichkeiten für maus und tastatur selbst während des spiels auch macros lassen sich
problemlos einsetzen damit sind sie bei flugsimulationen rennspielen und anderen
games decken der fanatic headshot controller ist das ultimative set für gamer und wetten dass er
auch als Geschenk gut ankommt.
Probieren Sie es aus.
Das ist so schlecht.
Oh Mann.
Das ist, wisst ihr,
das sind Sendungen, die richten sich an irgendwelche
Omas oder so, die ihren Enkeln
was zu Weihnachten schenken sollen
und nicht wissen was. Und was weiß ich,
der Enkel hat sich irgendwie eine neue
Gaming-Maus, neue Tastatur, was auch immer
gewünscht. Er kriegt jetzt den Fanatic Headshot
Controller. Hey, da haben wir das
Neue, das ausparkt doch.
Wo wir gerade dabei waren.
Ja, ich bin
geboren. Da.
Da bin ich geboren.
1929, easy.
Schmerzt schon, wenn ich es sehe.
Warum ist das mixt?
Soll doch eigentlich ganz gut sein.
Incredible Disappointing.
Ah, okay,
es gibt Uplay-Probleme.
Ja gut, Uplay ist ja auch der sinnloseste
Scheiß, der jemals erfunden wurde.
Ne, da warte ich erst noch mal mit Kaufen.
Quantum Break, ja,
das will ich, das wollte ich schon immer mal spielen.
Oh, da haben wir irgendwas übersprungen.
Quantum Break, easy.
Äh,
achso, ja, ja, bla.
Das wollte ich schon immer mal spielen.
Dachte mir, ich hole es mir für die Xbox,
dass ich wenigstens mal ein gescheites Game für die Xbox
habe, aber ich habe es mir dann nie für die
Xbox geholt. Aber ich bin ja
ein großer Fan der,
äh, Remedy-Games.
Gab ja nicht so wirklich viele.
Aber sowohl Max Payne,
1, 2 und, äh,
Alan Wake sind beides richtig geile Games.
Und Sam Lake
kann einfach Storys schreiben.
Ed.
Ja, komm, haben wir doch, es ist doch, es geht doch.
Guck mal, da hätten wir jetzt hier schon mal richtig vier
nice Games.
Und erst noch 43, oh, da geht noch was.
Is YouTube Money, is life.
Aber ansonsten noch.
Global Space Program ist nicht meins.
Ist aber ein geiles Game,
der halt tüfteln will.
Nope.
Gibt es jetzt auch für die Switch?
Moment, was?
Was soll das für ein Game sein? Das ist doch ein
Hardware-Teil. Damit kann ich
dann jetzt von Steam auf den Fernseher
oder so streamen. Aber kann ich auch
so, weil ich habe Nvidia Shield TV
und damit kann ich auch streamen.
Und das funktioniert wahrscheinlich besser.
The Forest. Nope.
Wo wir wieder beim Thema sind, warum
so viel Open World Survival?
Habe ich irgendwas im Chat oder was denn?
Wenn du es im Windows Store kaufst, bekommst du es
gerade für die Xbox One. Ach, ist mir wurscht.
Ich werde es eh nie
auf der Xbox One spielen.
Oh, das war nice. Das war auch nice.
Also wenn irgendjemand auch noch ein bisschen
düsteres Game sucht, hier.
Sehr nice.
Vor allem in Anbetracht
des Budgets, was sie
da gesichtsanimationstechnisch gemacht
haben.
Echt nice.
Gameplay-technisch war ein bisschen doof.
Aber es war von Anfang bis Ende
spannend.
Super
Voice-Over, halt
schöne Sprachausgabe und super Animation.
War echt cool.
Hallo? Steam?
Äh, Steam?
Äh, nope.
Also habe ich es eh schon.
Haben wir es schon anguckt?
Moment, Moment.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Sekunde.
995?
Das werde ich mir nicht alles angucken können.
Vielleicht sollte ich das mal filtern nach Sachen,
die mich interessieren.
Relevanz. Es ist ja schon nach Relevanz sortiert.
Was auch immer Relevanz ist.
Was ist das?
Sieht nach Echtzeitstrategie so ein bisschen aus.
Mit Figuren, die aussehen wie
Mies.
Ach, Early Access.
Okay. Und tschüss.
Ich will Early Access filtern.
Ich will sowas.
Not Early Access.
Geht das aufs...
Weiß jemand, ob das auf Steam geht?
Dass ich sagen kann, ich will kein Early Access sowieso.
Not, not Early...
Ich will Early Access rausfiltern.
Geht das irgendwie?
Ne, natürlich nicht.
Kein Wunder, dass man da nicht mehr durchblickt.
So, jetzt machen wir mal ein bisschen was.
Bisschen was zackigeres an.
Irish, Irish Christmas Music.
So. Ähm, vielleicht sollten wir doch hier mal...
Ähm, vielleicht sollten wir doch hier mal...
Doch hier nach den Empfehlungen gehen.
Weil 995 Seiten kann ich mir nicht angucken.
Das ist ein bisschen viel.
Harrys Mord haben wir schon. Terraria ist alt.
Alex.
Weiß ich nicht.
Kann man in meinem Profil, kann man im Profil einstellen, okay?
Werde ich irgendwann mal spielen.
Aber nicht in nächster Zeit.
Survival.
Sieht schon irgendwie...
Anhand der Bilder.
Survival?
Nice. Sehr nice gewesen.
Habe ich schon durchgespielt.
Sogar Let's Played.
Auf YouTube.
Tekken 7? Nope.
Shadow of Lootbox?
Nope.
Survival? Nope.
Ähm...
Nope.
Gibt es irgendwas, was mich interessiert vielleicht noch?
Nein? Survival?
Es ist krass zu sehen, wie viel
Survival am Start ist, oder?
Filter by Selected Types
nur nach Games und Bundles. Das ist eine gute Idee.
Es sind ja nur noch
551 Seiten.
Hast du das
neue Wolfenstein gespielt? Nein.
Habe ich nicht. Weil...
Weil, ich zeige es euch gleich.
Falls es überhaupt
dabei steht. Das da.
Deswegen.
Mir ist es scheißegal, ob die Hakenkreuze oder
sonstige Sachen, Symbole
aus dem 2. Weltkrieg und der Zeit drum herum
rausgeschippt haben. Das ist mir egal.
Das verstehe ich ja. Hey, das verstößt tatsächlich gegen
Deutsch. Ist okay.
Aber keine englische Sprachausgabe.
Was soll denn der Scheiß?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Deswegen habe ich mir nicht gekauft.
Gibt es irgendwie eine
Möglichkeit, weiß das jemand,
dass Wolfenstein 2
in Deutschland
zu bekommen, halt mit englischer
Sprache?
Bei irgendeinem anderen Shop oder so?
Oder ist einfach schlicht und ergreifend die Version halt
ohne Englisch?
Ich meine, ansonsten ist es mal wieder so ein typischer Fall von
Lädst du das illegal
runter, kriegst du das bessere Spiel.
Was wir ja hier keinen anstiften wollen.
Das ist einfach so der Fail,
was früher auch die Musikindustrie
und sowas gemacht hat.
Man hat den Leuten permanent ein schlechtes Gewissen
eingeredet. Kennt ihr noch von
Filmen früher, und ich weiß nicht, ob es das immer noch gibt,
vor den Filmen so dieses
Mama, wo ist Papa?
Im Knast, weil er Raub kopiert hat.
Da ist der Werbespot da.
Wo ich mir auch immer gedacht habe,
hey, ich würde viele Sachen gerne
im Original kaufen, wenn es die denn
gäbe in Deutschland. Und nicht irgendwie erst
ein Jahr später, mit
Kack-Tonspur, eventuell gar nicht,
eventuell mega teuer.
Die Leute
sind ja prinzipiell bereit, sich das alles
Original zu kaufen.
Wenn es halt was ordentliches gibt.
So.
So viel Joy.
Moment.
Ich bin falsch.
Specials.
Games.
Hab ich jetzt gefiltert? Games Bundles.
Okay.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Was haben wir uns schon alles
angeguckt? Wir gucken jetzt noch ein bisschen durch.
Ich mein, selbst 551 Seiten
kriegen wir nicht hin, aber es ist ja schon
nach Relevanz sortiert.
Übrigens, danke für die Followers. Ich muss mal reingucken.
Hab ich's denn hier?
Äh, Steamlabs?
So.
Genau.
Genau, Bestia. Das mein ich. Raubkopieren
mit bis zu 7 Jahren.
Das macht das vor allem sich. Das Beste
ist ja, dass dieser komische Werbespot
immer vor Filmen lief, wenn man die sich
gekauft hat.
Also sprich, du hast dir den Film ehrlich gekauft
oder was auch immer. Oder warst du im Kino
oder sonst was. Also sprich, du gibst Geld dafür aus
und dann musst du dir erstmal anhören,
wie schlimm es ist, Raub zu kopieren.
Äh, Sam Fisher,
ich hab grad das Fenster refreshed. Ich hab nicht gesehen, was du
äh, was du geschrieben hast.
So.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Jetzt haben wir uns doch schon alles angeguckt.
Dead by Daylight, Survival Zeug.
Dead Cells.
Das sieht auf den ersten Blick schon mal nach nem coolen
Grafikstil aus.
Also der Grafikstil gefällt mir.
Oh, weihnachtlicher wird's ja nicht
mehr jetzt, ey.
Jetzt wird's nicht mehr weihnachtlicher.
Warum muss Maria eigentlich
unbedingt Virgin sein? Das hab ich bis heute
nicht verstanden.
Vor allem der arme Joseph, ey.
Was hat er denn die ganze Zeit?
Egal, da wollen wir uns jetzt nicht so im Detail
mit beschäftigen.
Wir sind ja ein christlicher Stream.
Kann man sowas ja nicht erzählen.
Das sieht nice aus. Ich hab keine Ahnung, um was es geht.
Rook Light
Metro
Metroidvania
Actionplatformer
Boah, krass. Da haben sie ja
wieder...
Man ist heute nicht mehr nur eine Sache bei
einem Game. Man ist nicht mehr ein Genre. Man ist heute
Rook Light
Metroidvania Actionplatformer
Es sieht aber cool aus.
Early Access, nein. Ich hab mir vorgenommen,
Leute, egal was ist,
wenn ich nicht schon mal ein Spiel
Wenn die nicht schon mal irgendein Early Access Spiel
gemacht haben, was erschienen ist
und dann auch halbwegs was getaugt hat,
ich kauf mir kein Early Access mehr.
Ich seh's mittlerweile echt nicht mehr ein.
So viel
Shit, der bei Early Access
drin ist und nie fertig wird.
Guckt euch mal Dates an.
Dates kommt jetzt demnächst raus.
Keine Starwars mehr haben.
Hat irgendwie vier Jahre
in Early Access geschimmelt.
Und das wars.
Oh, das ist für die ganzen Anime-Fans hier.
Bei der Tales of Reihe
hab ich komplett den Überblick verloren,
was da jetzt wie aktuell ist.
Da kam so
alle zwei Jahre mal ein Teil raus.
Heute kommt gefühlt auf jeder
Plattform, jedem Jahr
ein Teil raus, da blickst du immer durch.
Außerdem wird das immer abgedreht.
Ich mein, hallo, kann ich nicht einfach
eine Rüstung anziehen?
Der Typ hier, übelste Schulter, Panzerung und alles
und die so, nein, hier, bauchfrei. Easy.
Bestgeschützte Parts hier am ganzen Körper.
Von oben bis da.
Tales of Symphonia auf dem Gamecube
war noch cool.
Und auch das für die
360, was es gab.
Aber mittlerweile hab ich da voll den Überblick verloren
bei der Reihe.
Also das ist ja auch, äh, Moment.
Das hab ich jetzt verwechselt.
Das ist, das sieht ja...
Nein.
Das wollte ich spielen.
Das wollte ich spielen,
das New Resident Evil.
Beziehungsweise Biohazard.
Also je nachdem, in welchem Land man das kauft.
Das ist ja auch witzig.
Irgendwie, dass es...
Das heißt ja irgendwie in Japan,
heißt es irgendwie Biohazard.
Bei uns heißt es Resident Evil.
Und bei uns heißt dieser Teil Resident Evil Biohazard.
Und in Japan heißt es Biohazard Resident Evil.
Mein Plohn.
Wenn man sich da zu lange Gedanken drüber macht,
dann platzt der Kopf.
Ähm...
Okay.
Das ist ja wieder so der typische Fall von
es gibt nicht einfach nur das Game,
na, okay, vergesst, was ich sagen wollte.
Es geht ja noch.
Ich wollte sagen, es gibt wieder 20 verschiedene Editions,
wo man nicht weiß, was man sich kaufen soll.
Das werde ich mir aber auf jeden Fall noch holen.
Nicht jetzt.
Er hat, er hat aber echt alles.
Er hat einfach alles.
Auf jedem Game, wo wir gucken, ist er am Start.
So, was haben wir
sonst noch hier? Sniper Elite 4.
Das haben wir schon.
Äh, nein.
Das ist nicht meins.
Also, Naruto ist doch mittlerweile eh
out, oder?
Ist das nicht sogar fertig?
Ist Naruto
nicht fertig mittlerweile?
Hab ich irgendwo mal gelesen.
Und es gibt jetzt ja wohl
irgendwie einen Sequel, äh, äh,
Pre-Sequel, so rum. Irgendwie mit dem Sohn
von Naruto dann und sowas.
Äh...
Nein.
What the fuck ist das?
Okay,
das sind die, die, äh, ähm,
Metal-Dings.
Wie heißt's?
Ey, ich hab übelst Probleme, in letzter Zeit mir Sachen zu merken,
wie was heißt.
Brutal Legends meine ich, genau.
What the fuck?
Soll das sein?
Multiplayer-Party-Game. Nein, das brauchen wir nicht.
Hab ich irgendwas überlesen im Chat?
Was wird's denn
real, ja?
So, was haben wir denn hier sonst noch?
Ahead in Time, das will ich haben.
Das
will ich haben.
Was ich auch ganz witzig finde, dass
Hüte dieses Jahr bei
Plattformern ganz voll im Trend sind.
Also, es gab zwei richtig gute
Plattformer mit, mit Hüten.
Einmal Ahead in Time und halt,
das andere werde ich ja kaum erzählen müssen, das wisst ihr eh.
Das neue Mario.
Deluxe Edition.
Das wollte ich aber schon die ganze Zeit mal spielen.
Hopp.
Was ist Hopp?
Bestimmt ein Unity-Game.
Irgendwie,
ich weiß nicht.
Es schreit irgendwie so ein bisschen danach.
Auch weil man das nicht wirklich erkennen
kann. Zumindest
ich kann das eigentlich erkennen, weil ich niemals damit
gemacht hab, großartig.
Was soll das sein?
Transform
the world of Hopp.
A new action adventure from
Runic Games. Runic Games?
Moment, was waren das?
Haben die nicht auf der Switch letztens
irgendwas released?
Muss ich mal gucken. Der Name sagt
mir irgendwas noch.
Was hat Runic Games gemacht?
Ah, ein Torchlight. Ah,
die sind das.
Steht so, hätte ich gar nicht gucken
müssen. Steht ja sogar drunter.
Torchlight. Okay, das hat mit Torchlight
aber relativ wenig zu tun.
Dann haben sie zumindest
einen, wenn man gescheite Games macht.
Aber es sieht nicht so aus, als wäre es jetzt was,
was ich unmittelbar spielen müsste.
Lies doch einen Satz weiter.
Jetzt weißt du, wie das mit Handbüchern lesen ist.
Limbo Chains.
Ich google das lieber, bevor ich das lese.
Borderlands 2 habe ich gespielt.
Noch auf der...
Was ist das? 360.
Mit dem Friseur zusammen.
Ein Ge...
Okay.
The fuck.
Irgendein Anime Prügelspiel.
Me Weep, Me Spam,
Mod Bucker, If Ban. Nein.
Steam.
H1
Z1. Warum habe ich mir dieses Game überhaupt
gekauft?
Kann mir das mal einer erklären?
Warum habe
ich mir das gekauft? Ich habe mir das schon vor 2 Jahren oder so gekauft.
Warum?
A Visual Novel ist es. Okay.
Halbtrain.
Halbtrain. Wahrscheinlich wegen dem Halbtrain habe ich mir das gekauft.
Warum habe ich mir das gekauft?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Bringt mir nichts, weil ich kein VR habe?
Kann ich es nicht ausschließen? Kein VR?
Das müssten die bei Steam echt machen.
Du müsstest negative Tags...
Also du könntest sagen, ich will alles außer VR.
Und sowas.
Dann hätten wir auch keine 500 noch was Seiten.
Ich habe überhaupt kein VR.
Age of Vampires 3 Complete Edition.
Haben wir schon. Geiles Game.
Zwar alt, aber geiles Game.
Das kam doch nicht erst 2012
raus. Das ist doch viel älter.
Age of Empires 3.
Muss ich mal gucken.
Das kam doch 2007 oder so. Das ist doch alt.
Ja, 2005 kam das raus.
Weiß auch nicht, was da Steam anzeigt.
Wahrscheinlich die Complete Edition kam 2012
raus.
Kingdom and Castles.
Das ist auch
neu und hat ein
bisschen Hype. Kann das sein?
Da schwingt irgendwas
im Kopf bei mir, wenn ich diesen Namen lese.
Kingdoms and Castles.
So, als hätte ich es schon mal irgendwo gesehen.
Okay, mittelaltiger
Städtebau Simulator.
Von Fick.
Manche Sachen sind echt unglücklich
in anderen Sprachen, oder?
Ist das Early Access?
Das ist nicht Early Access.
Das ist ein Pluspunkt.
Okay.
Ne, das werde ich...
Vielleicht irgendwann mal an. Das sieht nicht schlecht aus.
Shadow of Lootbox
hatten wir schon.
Da waren wir doch schon. Ich bin zur Seite.
Zurück.
Nein.
Das ist doch noch ein...
Das ist doch noch ein 360 Game oder so.
Never ist das von 2016.
Das ist ein Xbox 360
Game, wenn ich jetzt nicht total fallen schläge.
Life is Strange Before the Storm.
Nein.
Aber nicht in nächster Zeit.
Wollte ich mir schon
die ganze Zeit mal angucken.
Aber es ist bestimmt ein Game,
womit man sich beschäftigen muss.
Was war denn das nochmal?
War das dieses Ninja, Ninja Taktik
Stealth Game?
Hardcore Tactical Stealth Game
Set in Japan. Ja, genau das.
Das ist das.
Also quasi Kommandos in Japan.
Wenn ich das noch richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Das sah ganz cool aus.
Das habe ich auch
gewischt irgendwann mal.
Also ich benutze diese Wischlichts ja nicht,
weil ich will, dass mir das jemand kauft oder so.
So einfach, dass ich mir das merken kann.
Zurück.
Steam.
Steam checkt das nicht so ganz, glaube ich.
Evil Within.
Nope. Kein Bock drauf.
Echt kein Bock drauf.
Das ist so ein Game, was...
was ich gelesen habe, ist ja sowohl der erste
noch der zweite Teil gar nicht wirklich schlecht.
Aber...
schockt mich nicht.
Er hat echt alles.
Schon wieder, ey.
Wer auf viel Text
steht,
mit guter Story,
kann sich das hier kaufen.
Zumal die Enhanced Edition
wirklich viel besser aussieht als das Original.
Viel, viel besser
als das Original.
Im Original war die Auflösung ungefähr so hier,
wie diese eine Ecke.
Ah, Planescape, das war schon ein geiles Game.
Nope, nope. Farming Simulator.
Nein.
Zu Zeiten, als es noch Hack and Slay war,
wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Farming Simulator 2017.
Farming into K17.
Lull.
Das nächste.
Call of the Wild.
Ein Jagdspiel.
Jawoll. Nein.
Age of Mythology.
Externet.
Das ist doch auch schon uralt.
Warum hat das alles Release Date 2014?
Das ist auch so von 2000.
Was weiß ich.
2004 oder so.
Das ist uralt.
Golf It.
Midigolf oder sowas. Nein.
Metal Gear Solid.
Nein, auch keinen Bock drauf.
Das zeigt schon gar keine
Vorschaubilder mehr an.
Hat keinen Bock mehr.
Nein.
Top Simulator.
Wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe,
ist das
im Endeffekt
um Games
in einem Game zu spielen, oder?
Oh, jetzt wird es aber echt
Inception-mäßig.
Wenn es in einem Spiel ein Tablet gibt mit Android
drauf, wo man wieder ein weiteres Spiel
und vielleicht das gleiche Spiel spielen kann,
indem man wieder ein Tablet hat mit Android drauf,
wo man das Spiel...
Das schafft mein Gehirn gerade nicht.
Es ist aber ein Spiel,
um ein Spiel zu spielen.
Es gibt schon mal die passenden Würfel,
um Dungeons & Dragons
spielen zu können.
Mit VR wäre das natürlich
übelst geil.
Das ist dann wirklich schon
Next Gen. Also sprich,
anstatt, dass man sich mit seinen Kumpels...
Ich meine, das ist jetzt wirklich nicht negativ.
Anstatt, dass man sich mit seinen Kumpels
an Tisch setzt in echt und das spielt,
kann man sich virtuell an Tisch setzen und spielen,
was natürlich in der heutigen Zeit
unglaubliche Vorteile hat,
weil man nicht zusammen in einem gleichen Raum sein muss.
Das ist eine coole Idee.
Da könnten wir
eigentlich unser D&D Zeug drin spielen.
What's my name?
Das würde mich nicht wundern.
Okay.
Vom Namen her ist es
irgendein Kunst-Game.
Oder auch nicht.
Der Treppenlift.
Interessiert mich nicht.
Bin gerade zu kommen. Was ist denn schon im Einkaufskorb?
Ähm...
Zeige ich dir.
Wenn ich wüsste, wie man auf den
Einkaufskorb kommt.
Wie kommen wir auf den Einkaufskorb?
Hier, Card.
Das haben wir zur Zeit im Card drin.
Ahead in Time, Quantum Break, Cuphead,
Hollow Knight und das erste
South Park Spiel.
Also, ein South Park RPG Spiel.
Slime Ranger.
Also, wenn ein Spiel einen richtig dummen Namen hat,
dann ist es ja mal Slime Ranger.
Was ist das?
What the fuck?
Was sehe ich da?
Also, ich habe jetzt
das Video gesehen und ich habe keine Ahnung,
was ich da gesehen habe, ehrlich gesagt.
Also, ihr könnt jetzt ja meinen Gesichtsausdruck
gerade nicht sehen, aber es ist so...
Oh, was geht?
Was, du saugst Schleim ein und züchtest den dann?
Braucht man dazu ein Game?
Elite Dangerous.
Warum hat das so, warum hat das so schlechte
Bewertung? Das heißt doch ganz gut gestartet.
Wie gewinnt man da?
Was weiß ich?
Ich habe es nicht gespielt.
Zumindest Schleim eins saugen kann man,
wenn man da drauf steht, auch ohne ein Spiel.
Wenn es einem gefällt.
Es gibt ja, egal,
man kann sich ja davon, man kann davon ausgehen,
egal was für kranke Sachen man sich ausdenken kann,
du wirst auf der Welt mindestens
jemanden finden, der es geil findet.
Deswegen gibt es bestimmt auch Leute,
die gerne Schleim einsauen.
Das ist doch übelst gut gestartet.
Warum hat das jetzt so schlechte Bewertung?
Was ist, was ist da los?
Okay, anscheinend hat es,
wenn man das eine Weile spielt,
ist es nicht so geil.
Okay, der Crying is real.
Das war nice.
Das würde ich gerne mal spielen.
Das war fast das ganze Game,
weil ich da schon so viele Streams und Speedruns
und Videos und so gesehen habe.
Aber das Game ist echt nice.
Ich weiß gar nicht,
ob ich es noch selbst spielen soll,
weil ich kenne es halt schon.
Starborn, nope.
Nope.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Dishonored, haben wir schon.
Nochmal Dark Souls.
Dark Souls wollen sie uns aber heute
von vorne bis hinten, an jeder Ecke
Dark Souls empfehlen.
Empire 2 in Just Nine.
Imperial Infinite
habe ich gespielt auf der
360 glaube ich noch.
Oder PS4?
360? PS4?
Weiß ich gar nicht mehr.
Sah ganz gut aus.
Also wahrscheinlich PS4.
Weiß nicht.
XCOM 2 irgendwann mal
ist definitiv ein gutes Game.
Hearts of Iron. Nein.
Das sieht mir nach irgend so einem
World Map Strategy Game
Truppenrum-Geschicke aus.
Das ist nichts für mich.
Stellaris hatte mal
eine Zeit ein bisschen Hype, sagt mir irgendwas,
hat mich aber auch nicht interessiert.
Bayonetta gab es für die...
Mist erzähle.
War das für die Wii der erste Teil?
Da ging der Friseur damals total
drauf ab. Auf das erste Bayonetta.
Das hat er bis in höchsten
Schwierigkeitsgrad mit allem durchgespielt.
Gefühlt drei Monate lang.
Farmers Dynasty.
Nee.
That is Strange. Kennen wir
schon ein bisschen her.
Killing Floor 2 habe ich die Beta
gespielt. War sinnlos im Kreis.
Monstergebäsche hat mir nicht gefallen.
Telltale? Nein.
Habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Flugsimulator.
Turmel 1 Simulator. Nein.
Watch Dogs 2? Nein.
Evolution? War nice.
Steep. Ach, das ist dieses
Snowboard-Game.
Nee, das ist auch nicht meins gewesen.
Dishonored 2 wollte ich irgendwann auch mal spielen,
aber erstmal nicht.
Ich habe gehört letztens irgendwo, dass
Dishonored 2
finanziell nicht so gut gewesen ist.
Würde mich eigentlich
wundern.
Nachdem der erste Teil ja wirklich
ziemlich gut war und
ich glaube auch ziemlich erfolgreich.
Project Cars.
Nein. Kein Bock auf Rennspiele.
BeamNG Drive.
Endless Space 2. Klingt nach
Survival. Ist bestimmt
Survival. Ich wette mit euch Survival.
Strategic Space
Opera featuring
Just
One More Turn Gameplay. Aha.
Okay, es ist
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen Survival
im Weltraum.
Erinnert mich ein bisschen an
Homeworld, wenn ich das so sehe.
Kennt das noch jemand?
Homeworld? Also das erste.
Was damals grafisch
extrem geil war mit den Raumschiffen.
Da muss man zu viel
da muss man zu viel denken.
Das krieg ich heute noch hin.
Battlestar Galactica
Deadline. Das liegt schon
der Titel. Da hab ich gar nicht Bock drauf.
Äh.
Nicht Skyrim, diesmal ist es Oblivion.
Näh.
Manche Sachen sehen schon irgendwie
so aus, als ist es nichts für mich.
Das wollte ich mal spielen.
Das ist von Obsidian glaub ich.
Ja.
Das wollte ich spielen.
Zum Release schon.
Bin ich aber irgendwie nicht zugekommen.
Und wahrscheinlich ist es auch ein Game, was eine Weile
dauert.
Wenn ich da an Pillars of Eternity denke.
Das konnte man ja auch gut und gern mal 80 Stunden spielen.
Das ist von den gleichen Typen.
Also Obsidian Entertainment hat ja schon vieles
in dieser Richtung gemacht.
Oh!
Es gibt ne Pillars of Eternity 2.
Gibt es da nen Early Access oder Crowd Founding
oder was ist das?
Da freu ich mich drauf. Wusste noch gar nicht, dass es in der Entwicklung ist.
Hast du schon mal
Spellforce 3 ausprobiert?
Nein hab ich nicht. Ich hab bloß gelesen, dass es
verbuggt sein soll wie Sau.
Dementsprechend dachte ich mir, ich warte einfach nochmal.
Also ich glaub so die Top Games
haben wir jetzt durch, wenn ich hier angucke, was
jetzt hier noch kommt.
Ja, Moment. Ich bin falsch.
Just Cause 3.
Nein.
Atmosphäre wirklich
super.
Oh, wieder mal im Themasinn. Er hat alles.
Ähm.
Angeblich das bessere SimCity.
Von allem, was ich gelesen hab. Nie ausprobiert.
Hab ich beim Lost im
Stream mal gesehen. Sah ganz spaßig aus.
Aber es schockt mich alles nicht so.
Übelst geiles Game. Hier. Hallo.
Übelst geiles Game.
Darkest Dungeon.
Gab's jetzt auch letztens in Addon zu.
Dungeon Crimes. So
2 1
halb D, wenn man die
Übersichts, Mini-Übersichtskarte mit
einrechnet. Na, eigentlich eher 2D.
Irgendwie
spricht mich da grad net so wirklich was an.
Das hab ich mir auch mal irgendwann
gekauft. Hab ich?
Hab ich net.
Wollte ich glaub ich mal, als es neu war.
Irgendwie
spricht mich grade nicht mehr
so viel an.
Was ist das?
WTF?
Das ist so ein typisches japanisches
Game, oder?
Das muss ein japanisches Game
sein.
Das können nur japanische Games sein.
Riesenameisen überfallen
irgendeine Stadt und du musst sie bashen. Das kann nur
ein japanisches Game sein.
Und hast ne MG, die aussieht
wie ne Armbrust, wo man nicht weiß, warum die so aussieht
wie ne Armbrust, weil es eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn hat, dass sie aussieht
wie ne Armbrust.
Das muss, das muss ein japanisches Game sein.
Das geht gar nicht anders.
Ach du Schei...
Es ist...
Japanischer geht's ja gar nicht mehr.
Ist das Multiplayer?
Koop.
Koop ist jedes Game spaßig.
Das wollen wir im Stream sehen.
Das ist doch das lieblings Game von all den 4 Games.
Ist es das?
In welch japanisch kann's nicht sein?
Echt, weil das sieht sogar ganz spaßig aus.
Das ist halt im Prinzip wahrscheinlich sowas wie
sinnloser endlos Horde Modus im Koop
einfach Monster bashen.
1000 Spielstunden hast du da drin.
Das muss man sich mal auf jeden Fall merken.
Nein, wenn ich so einen Titel schon...
Das liest sich nach Survival.
Sieht aber nicht so aus wie Survival.
Aber Grafikstil hat mir jetzt nicht so gefallen.
Autorennspiele...
Nein, Far Cry 4 haben wir schon.
Castle Crashers auch nice, aber schon uralt.
Halo Wars?
Nein.
Wenn ich mal ein bisschen deprimiert sein will zu Weihnachten, dann spiele ich das.
Also wenn einer zu gut drauf ist
zu dieser Jahreszeit
und sich ein bisschen mal
ein bisschen deprimiert sein will, dann kann er das War of Mind spielen.
Oder er spielt To The Moon.
Dann kann er eine Runde heulen.
E-Sport? Lull?
Kartenzeug?
Ich bin im ersten Teil, da hab ich mir mal angeguckt.
Irgendwie springt
mir grad nicht superhot
superhot, auf VR jetzt
sogar.
Ich konnte ehrlich gesagt die
Begeisterung um superhot
nicht so ganz nachvollziehen.
Salt & Sanctuary.
Ist das, wenn man zu viel Overwatch Ranked gespielt hat?
Das ist quasi Overwatch Ranked
als eigenes Game.
Salt & Sanctuary.
So, was ist... Hallo?
Ich hab draufgeklickt, Steam.
Steam, ich hab draufgeklickt.
Okay, der Grafikstil, den finde ich ganz nice.
Och nee, das ist wieder irgendein
Open World, random generated
sonst was Survival Zeugs, oder?
Na...
Wo haben wir denn aufgehört?
Heute kein Overwatch, nee.
Leute, ich kann's noch mal sagen, ey.
Wirklich super Game.
Wenn ihr ein Spiel sucht mit sehr viel
Herz, dann holt euch
Finding Paradise.
Ein Game, was ich prinzipiell auch gern
noch mal im Stream durchspielen würde,
was ganz gut ist,
weil es ist komplett auf Englisch,
das heißt, ich muss das irgendwie so sinngemäß übersetzen,
wenn ich das spiele.
Und manche Dialoge haben Wörter drin,
wo ich selbst erst mal nachgucken musste,
wo ich gedacht hab, was wollt ihr da eigentlich?
Ähm...
Aber nachdem ich quasi so die letzte
Stunde von dem Game übelst geheult
hab, hab ich mir gedacht, ist das vielleicht nicht
das beste On-Stream? Oder vielleicht ist es,
wäre das gerade das beste On-Stream?
Keine Ahnung.
Torchlight 2, ja, schon
abgehakt.
Pro Evolution Soccer, nein.
Fußballspiele,
nein.
Muss auch nicht sein.
Noch mehr Superhot.
Crim Dawn.
Diablo Schnetzlor.
Sprich mich aber auch
nicht so richtig an.
Heatsignature.
Was ist das?
Äh...
Hä?
Okay, das ist definitiv ein Game, wo ich
anhand der Screenshots keine Ahnung hab, um was es geht.
Was passiert da überhaupt?
Okay, ich versteh nicht, um was
es geht.
Irgendeine Weltraumstelle.
Surtle-G, sonstwas Game.
Ein Rooklike-Raumschiff-Einbrech-Spiel.
Okay, wenn
du das so sagst...
Ton an, da gibt's
bestimmt einfach nur epische Musik.
Oh ne, da wird was erklärt. Fuck.
Das hätte ich vielleicht doch den Ton anmachen sollen.
So.
Ähm...
Was haben wir denn sonst noch so?
Das soll ganz nice sein, was ich gelesen hab.
Moment.
Online? Morrowind?
What?
Ah, das ist ein
Add-On für Elder Scrolls Online, was
zufälligerweise Morrowind heißt.
Wo man quasi in dem
Gebiet spielt,
vom damaligen Singleplayer-Spiel.
Fragezeichen.
Wahrscheinlich.
Max, wie wäre es, du lädst dir Unity runter
und wir entwickeln zusammen ein Spiel.
Ich hab keine Ahnung von Unity.
Außerdem bräuchte man da erstmal
eine gute Idee.
Space Engineers.
Sieht ein bisschen so was aus wie
Kerbal Space Program.
Nein.
Die Lego-Spiele, finde ich, haben wir auch ganz schön
nachgelassen. Ich fand die ersten paar Lego-Games
mega nice. So Lego Indiana Jones
und was war denn das nächste?
Ähm...
Mir fällt eigentlich bloß noch
Lego Indiana Jones ein.
Die ersten Lego-Games fand ich übelst nice.
Danach, finde ich, hat es
irgendwie nachgelassen. War auch ein bisschen immer das gleiche.
Stalker. Nice Games.
Er hat echt alle Games.
Soma.
Was ist Soma?
Ah, die Typen sind das. Okay.
Science-Fiction-Horror-Games
set below the waves of the Atlantic Ocean.
Struggle to
Survive.
Das klingt aber schon wieder so nach Survival
und Open World und so.
Warum gibt es so viele Survival-Open-World-Games?
Die müssen ja noch nicht mal schlecht sein,
aber ich finde dieses Short, das ist mittlerweile so
ausgelutscht. So ausgelutscht
wie Zombie-Survival oder
MOBAs oder so.
Ohne dass das jetzt, dass das hier
schlecht sein muss, weil wenn man sich die Bewertung anguckt,
ist das wahrscheinlich sogar ziemlich gut.
Der Masterbrook, das stimmt.
Fürs Spiele-Programmieren braucht man keine Ahnung mehr. Einfach Early Access
und fertig. Ja, wenn man sich anguckt, wie viele Scheiß-Spiele
mittlerweile im Early Access hier rumschimmeln,
wo sich Leute quasi
das SDK runtergeladen haben
oder irgendein Engine mit ein paar
Demos drin, ein Demo-Level,
hinsetzen drei Bäume rein und sagen dann
hier, Next-Gen,
ultrakrasser sonst was Shooter
und wollen dann 15 Euro für Early Access.
Und am besten bauen sie noch irgendwas
ein, was so richtig schlecht ist,
dass dann Let's-Player kommen können und
funny, funny Streams drüber machen,
funny Videos drüber machen.
Wisst ihr, es gibt so viele
Spiele, so irgendwie, was, was, was es nicht alles
gab. Goat-Simulator, Crash-Simulator,
äh, äh,
es gibt bestimmt auch Shit-Simulator
wahrscheinlich mittlerweile.
So Kack-Games eigentlich.
So richtig dummes Zeug,
wo es alle mega lustig finden,
dass, dass irgendwelche,
Physik-Sachen nicht richtig funktionieren,
irgendwelche Ragdoll-Geschichten nicht richtig
funktionieren und alle, hoho, es ist lustig,
lululul, lass mal alle hier Let's-Play
machen.
Wir sind da auch ein Teil, also die ganzen
YouTube-Let's-Play-Geschichten und diese
Funny-Let's-Play sind auch zum Teil mit dran
schuld, dass es so viele Scheiß-Games gibt.
G-Simulator,
was auch immer es da alles gibt.
Ja. Der Hand-Simulator,
sind wir doch grad dabei.
Dafuck, was zum Teufel ist
der Hand-Simulator?
Warum?
Wer, wer hat diese Models erstellt?
Und warum ist
das mostly positive?
Das sieht schon, das sieht schon absolut nach
unfertigem Kack aus.
Ah, Simulator.
Das hat so eine Poppe in letzter Zeit
gespielt. Ja, genau nach so einem Game
sieht es aus.
Da warst du Patient-Simulator.
Ja.
Sollten sie mal so nennen,
das Ding, ja.
Erinnert mich irgendwie an Reaper,
wenn er portet.
Death Calls.
So, wir brauchen neue Weihnachtsmusik,
das ist fertig.
Wir brauchen, okay, ich geh jetzt zu YouTube.
Best Christmas Songs.
Mal gucken, was es da gibt.
Top Christmas Songs
of all time.
Okay, wahrscheinlich ist das jetzt
grausam.
Max, schaust du dir eigentlich Gamestar an?
Ja, ab und zu.
Oh, ne.
Best Christmas, oh, Moment, das muss mal,
ja, das muss, das muss sein.
Bisschen leise, oder?
So.
Ist das Falco, ne? Das sind die Toten Rosen.
Nein, die Roten Rosen, sorry.
So, was haben wir denn jetzt hier noch?
Cringe.
So, was gibt's denn hier sonst noch schönes?
Steam.
Golf with your friends, nein.
Vanquished, nein.
Hollow Knight ist im Angebot.
Dazu kann ich bloß sagen,
Hollow Knight, bam.
Du kannst mal nach Rainbow Six Siege schauen,
vielleicht ist das im Angebot. Ja, das ist im Angebot.
Das habe ich mir aber schon gekauft.
Gestern.
Vorgestern, vorgestern.
Moin, Notwehr87.
Und sind da echt viele Leute dafür,
dass ich einfach nur sinnlos in Steam rumklicke?
Vogel.
Nicht Vogel, Vogel.
Moment.
Das ist Minecraft aus Vogelsicht.
Was zum...
Okay, bei manchen Games frage ich mich jetzt,
warum gibt's die?
EXPERIENCE DEVICE.
The thrilling flying as you explore
the natural beauty of a
vast voxel world.
Thrilling. Ja, voll...
Ist das thrilling.
Krass, das ist ja so nervenaufreibend.
Sieht nach Foxel-Grafik aus, ja.
Ist es auch.
Nein, Vogel. Brauch nicht.
Moment.
Steam hat's mit der Zurück-Taste nicht so wirklich
besiegt. Wird das eigentlich jetzt noch
weiterentwickelt?
Ist das eigentlich mittlerweile fertig?
Nein, immer noch Early-Exercise 2015.
Ob das jemals
fertig wird?
Anscheinend sind die wirklich starker gut dabei
und basteln rum.
Ja, Update 15. Dezember,
18. Dezember.
Level-Editor. Okay, die sind wohl wirklich noch dicke dabei.
Hi, Levi.
Lawbreakers.
Ist auch so ein Fail-Game.
Hab ich am Anfang mal kurz überlegt,
aber das war so ein Game, was quasi schon
bei Release
gewesen ist.
Ja, genau so sah's für mich auch aus.
Weniger
Spiele als das Game kostet.
Okay, ich glaub die guten Games haben wir jetzt
durch.
Das sieht mir nach nem typischen
Game aus. Ich hab ne Unity runtergeladen
und einfach mal ne
Cringe-Song.
Warum?
Gute Version davon.
So, was empfiehlt uns denn hier Steam?
Ey, Anime-Battle-Zeug.
Muss nicht sein.
Ich brauch nochmal irgendein gutes
Album-Weihnachtslieder. Was gibt's denn da?
Hat jemand gute Vorschläge?
Ich brauch irgendwie
Christmas...
Was haben wir denn hier?
Bad Religion Christmas-Song.
Die haben einen Christmas-Song?
Okay. Auch sehr nice Band.
Oh fuck, das sind ja echt
Christmas-Songs.
Bad Religion hab ich früher
sehr viel gehört.
Ups.
Bethlehem,
okay. Also,
ich glaub wir haben jetzt so mehr oder weniger
interessante Sachen durchgeguckt, ne?
Das haben wir alle schon hier gesehen.
Geht ab.
Was Cooles gefällt mir.
Ähm. Hast du schon ne Long Dark
gesehen? Ja, hab ich schon gesehen.
Aber hab ich erst mal nicht gekauft.
Batman,
nee.
Oh, da bin ich mal gespannt,
was das für Bewertungen hat.
Da müssen wir mal
die Bewertung müssen wir jetzt mal angucken.
Okay, was hat's für Bewertungen?
Weil das soll ein richtig
Kack-Remastered sein, was ich bisher so gelesen
hab.
Ja, Spiel kommen, Alter. Genau, das ist auch so ein Problem.
Naja.
So, was empfehlen
denn meine Friends
sonst noch so?
Highlights. More Highlights.
More Highlights.
Train Simulator.
Warum ist das Based on
Based on my Preferences
der Train Simulator?
Poly Bridge ist gut.
Okay, was ist das?
Wie viele Anime-Games es gibt?
Poly Bridge. Das ist Bridge Builder.
Das ist sowas wie Bridge Builder. Ah, das ist cool.
Komm,
5,99.
Ja, das ist sowas wie Bridge Builder.
Eigentlich, weil wir
Bridge Builder.
Oh, das ist ein bisschen komplexeres Bridge Builder,
wie es ausschaut.
Das ist cool.
Ich überleg grad, ob ich mir das kaufe.
Bridge Constructor Portal.
Schon
angeschaut. Nein.
Bridge Constructor
Portal? Hat das was mit Portal
zu tun oder heißt es einfach nur so
Early Access?
Komm, das
kaufen wir jetzt. Das sieht wirklich spaßig aus.
Bridge Constructor
Portal.
Fuck, es ist echt Portal.
Es ist...
Dass die Portal verwenden dürfen?
Kauft ihr lieber das?
Weiß nicht.
Bridge Constructor Portal.
Wir tun, was wir müssen, weil wir es können.
Für das Gute für uns alle, außer für diejenigen, die tot sind.
Aber es ist kein Sinn, über alle Fehler zu weinen.
Du bleibst nur noch versuchen, bis du ein neues Problem lernst.
Und die Wissenschaft wird gemacht, und du wirst einen neuen Plan machen,
weil die Menschen, die noch wohnen,
I'm being so sincere right now.
You broke my heart and killed me.
I'm releasing on time, so I'm glad I'm still alive.
Weiß nicht, 19? Oder sowas?
So voll mit Schleimfrisur, also so voll ordentlich, so mit Hemd und Dings hier,
also jetzt keine Turnschuhen, mit richtig ordentlichen Schuhen, Hemd und allem an,
voll Gel- und Schleimfrisur, hab ich dann in die Kamera gegrinst.
Und ich hab mir überlegt, ob ich das Foto nicht mal in irgendeinem Video zeigen soll,
weil ich seh eh nicht mehr so aus.
Ich hab gefühlt die Hälfte der Haare nicht mehr, die ich da war,
auf dem Foto.
Also ich wieg bestimmt 20 Kilo mehr als auf dem Foto.
Und, ähm, hab nur noch die Hälfte der Haare.
Also insofern, ich glaub mal, der kennt mich dann eh nicht.
Na, Glatzkopf mag's noch nicht.
Es ist aber halt, es ist an einigen Stellen schon relativ dünn.
Sagen wir's mal so.
Glatze ist es nicht.
Damals hatte ich auch noch kein Bart.
Ja.
Hast du eigentlich noch was mit dem Krieger zu tun?
Nicht, ne.
Dü-dü-dü-dü.
Glatz-FPS.
Moin, Barthoven.
Gut.
Also ich würd sagen, wir machen jetzt Schluss.
Ich hoffe, es hat euch gefallen.
Haben wir ein paar Sachen gefunden, die man sich geben kann, spieletechnisch.
Und mal gucken, ob ich noch irgendein...
Wie könnte ich denn mal hosten?
Sagt man ja, mal gucken.
Wer spielt?
Wer tiltet sich denn in Overwatch ein ab?
Gibt's da, gibt's da grad einen?
Wer tiltet sich irgendwie in Overwatch ein ab, den man hosten könnte?
Zeigt mal her.
Ne, keinen, den ich kenne.
Kami spielt nicht.
Hm.
Gucken.
Wie hosten jetzt Bob Ross?
Der Mesh, der Mesh spielt Battlefield.
Den könnte man hosten.
Komm, wir hosten mal den Mesh.
Den wollte ich auch noch was aufnehmen in nächster Zeit.
Der Mesh fällt mir gerade so ein.
Mario Galaxy Soundtrack, der ist so geil.
Oder vor allem diese Stelle hier.
Sagt mal, warte mal, ich spule mal kurz zurück.
Das finde ich so geil.
Das hier.
Wartet hier.
Das jetzt.
Ist doch so nice, der Soundtrack.
Was auch richtig geil ist, weil wir gerade dabei sind.
Und weil der Breath of the Wild Soundtrack meiner Ansicht nach doof war.
Ja.
Ist.
Das Deathrowel-Theme von Skyward Sword, das ist auch geil.
Übelst nice, oder?
Geht jetzt noch sieben Minuten.
Nur mal nebenbei, hat's so angemerkt.
Ähm.
Also, ich hoffe, euch hat's gefallen.
Wir machen jetzt.
Moment, ist der Mesh jetzt off?
Alles klar, Leute.
Macht's gut.
Äh, in fünf, also um 14 Uhr gibt's das Video mit dem Fabian bei mir auf dem Channel.
Bis dann, macht's gut.
Tschüss.